there is this memo that leaked from
Google here I'll just read a little bit
of the note the uncomfortable truth is
we aren't positioned to win this arms
race and neither is open Ai and what
this memo author is saying is that
Google's competitor is not really open
AI or any other firm but actually open
source models meta's training data I
guess leaked out and open source
Engineers have been
uh creating AIS on that data that seem
to at least according to this author uh
be catching up to what openai and Google
are doing and he says they're doing
things with a hundred dollars and 13
billion parameters that we struggle with
at 10 million and 540 billion how much
Credence do you give that that you know
the open source movement is going to
kind of catch up or maybe even lap the
big centralized firms
Philippine source uh until we can wear
that large has been working on has been
working from the
from the kind of biggest open source
available uh pre-trained system that I
think for a while and perhaps still it
was the Facebook llama that they trained
and in my opinion like completely
responsibly just dumped on the world
uh so uh so like the open source
certainly currently does not have the
ability to throw like hundreds of
millions of dollars or again soon to be
billions billions at this large AI
summoning experiments when Robin said
that
like he would be worried if people would
be on deliberately and try to create
like worst uh worst case scenarios make
AI that you destroy the world
deliberately well
open source uh that's how like if you
it's not hard to find or the existing
projects that try to use uh open uh
Source uh AIS to maximize the damage I
mean the day I found that competitive
that competent yet so they take off like
a more sort of fun and games project at
this point but
this is just like uh early uh how would
you even regulate open source
development of these products I mean
that that kind of seems to undercut the
entire idea of there's even much you
could do about it
yeah so like I mean we already have uh
you know penalties for developing
viruses and stuff like that so it's it's
uh like uh something probably could be
uh develop some kind of liability uh it
can be assigned uh from there but but I
I agree this is like super super much
more harder than just like making sure
that you're not going to summon even
your more competent minds and and
release them uh on the public so here's
a another compromise solution I know
people who work on secure operating
systems who say that you can provably uh
show that some operating systems are
completely secure and maybe you could
just require they use those operating
systems for the
uh 200 lines of code here that would be
a relatively low cost honestly
and it would actually help kick start
the secure operating system world and
that seems like a reasonable regulation
that would be relatively low cost uh
addresses your most direct concern here
uh again I'm looking for compromises I'm
looking for things we can agree on yep
like 100 agreed but really important the
companies are currently racing and they
are not motivated to take any of those
steps
the danger here is if we Empower some
regulatory body to do stuff it won't
just want to do a few best things it'll
have a big public behind it and they
want to you know take make speeches and
show how concerned they are and just do
a lot of extra too much stuff so uh we
want maybe even if we authorize some
regulation to make it limited and that's
part of the problem here the regulation
isn't often limited what are your major
concerns with what
non-careful regulation
might do in terms of our the development
of this technology well Humanity in the
last century uh basically shut down
nuclear energy industry pretty
effectively and we basically said no we
didn't want to go there with modest
exceptions uh more recently we basically
shut down genetic engineering and said
no we didn't want to go there
uh we may just see AI that way and want
to shut it down that is I I some people
say that this we really couldn't
regulate this that would be infeasible
it's too spread out and too too many
strong interests look at the past I'd
say it is possible to strongly regulate
some Industries in there is strong
public opinion uh in support of being
wary of AI and holding it back so I fear
the worst case of really just shutting
down the whole industry and really
foregoing enormous potential if the
government and various Regulators around
the world fail to
Crush Ai and its infancy what is what
are the prospects about an AI
future an AI dominated future let's say
that most excite you
well so over the last few decades we've
seen many new exciting Technologies
appear
compared to those this is more exciting
because it seems to have more tantal but
it's also in some sense more democratic
that is most of the people figuring out
what this can do are just people trying
it themselves they don't need to get a
big startup and lots of funding they
just start using this in their ordinary
business life and see what can happen
and that's really exciting because if a
lot of them find a lot of useful
applications we're just going to get
this big wave of productivity where a
lot of people figure out a lot of ways
to do things better
and that will not only make us all
richer and healthier but it will make
more of a sense that we should be
expecting and wanting Innovation and
change and Technology to spread and more
of an optimism that the future could be
better because of that and more of a an
eagerness to maybe instead of looking
for all the things that could go wrong
and trying to fix them that we should be
looking for all the things that go right
and how to encourage them and that
sounds like an exciting future over the
next decade is a world gets more
optimistic and excited because great
stuff is happening and they're more
interested in pursuing new options than
in closing them off and then complaining
about why things aren't better hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our live stream with Robin Hansen and
Jan tallin about artificial intelligence
existential risk and the dangers of
preemptive regulation you can watch our
full conversation right here or another
excerpt right here